so my fault i can't save everyone
hey it's carlos for et canada's nerd
alert the hype for spider-man no way
home has been intense to say the least
with more leaks than a tugboat and a
thunderstorm now full disclosure i have
seen the movie which would give me the
power to spoil it for you but as we all
know the great power comes great
responsibility so no rather than getting
into all that let's take a look at the
world peter parker and his amazing
friends find themselves in as they begin
this chapter no way home takes place
immediately following the events of the
last spider-man movie far from home with
the world now aware that spider-man is
actually peter parker but where does
that sit on the mcu timeline
so the ordering of the marvel movies and
shows can be confusing the release dates
of each project often don't line up with
the order of events that take place in
the stories but we're here to help sort
it out and get everything in order
before you see the movie this weekend if
you've been keeping up with phase four
you'll know that black widow took place
way back in 2016 years before natasha
sacrificed herself to save the universe
the post avengers and game mcu kicked
off with wand division which takes place
several weeks after the avengers brought
everyone back from the blip in late 2023
fast forward a few months on the prime
timeline and you've got the introduction
of xiangxi as well as sam wilson taking
up the mantle of captain america and
falcon and the winter soldier which is
said to take place six months after end
game eternal spans pretty much all of
human existence but the modern day
events are supposed to be happening
around the same time as spider-man far
from home which is eight months after
end game in the summer of 2024 and that
of course brings us to no way home which
picks up right where far from home ended
and goes until at least the halloween
season but ends before hawkeye tries to
get home for the holidays in that
current disney plus series now as for
loki that takes place outside of the
timeline with the multiverse being born
at the citadel at the end of time you
got all that
i promise it makes sense and as for that
multiverse that everyone's talking about
it will be a central part of the mcu
moving forward and plays a huge part in
spider-man noway home
now if you do end up seeing it this
weekend please don't spoil the surprises
for anyone else and if you already think
you know everything the movie has to
offer just wait till you see it it's
going to be worth it that's it for me
i'll see you next time
you